they're an infinite number of terrible
things that happen in Philadelphia like
in any other city but it just so happens
that like this robot brings it to the
attention of like the international
community it's embarrassing that
somebody came to United States and when
you trashed it
I mean it's kind of a personal tragedy
because Philadelphia is action epicenter
for great robotics work so to have
hitchbot you know kind of meet its and
meet its demise here in Philadelphia is
really an affront to us for roboticists
I heard that there are all these
families with kids who really loved
robots that had been following the story
and so they're really bummed and I was
like okay now I know lily is gonna get
blamed for this if the one sort of
silver lining this it helps bring people
together helped to highlight the
research that was happening helps
highlight some of the great things that
are happening not just in Philadelphia
all around the world in research
you